the trailer for the new ant-man and the  wasp has leaked and i'm going to show  you guys and break down the reveal for  kang so ant-man says i don't know who  you are but you've made a big mistake  i'm an avenger in which kang menace lee  responds with  [Music]  and i got to say the delivery done by  kang here is just amazing i can just  tell this is going to be a darker marvel  film and this villain is going to just  such a great addition to the mcu  unfortunately i can't show too much more  footage because i don't want to risk a  copyright strike but what do you guys  think do you like the review of kang  here let me know in the comment section  below and if you haven't already i would  appreciate if you would subscribe and  like to show your support thanks for  watching guys